victor à quatre mois il vient d'arriver
dans le service de neurochirurgie
pédiatrique de l'hôpital necker dans le
15e arrondissement de paris
[Musique]
il faut juste qu'on va mettre du plateau
devenant dormir
la criée glisse-t-il voire mal à la tête
les vraiment pas mieux et sinon il est
très longue et il n'est pas il réagit
pas il demandait rien donc ça c'est pas
bien c'est pas normal il ya quelques
heures victor a été pris d'un brusque
malaise chez sa nourrice c'est en
urgence que le samu l'a conduit à necker
[Musique]
je ne crois pas au téléphone
je vais d'hydra première balle 11 heures
mais insiste matin certains
affiliés quelqu'un
on va se faire mais très près depuis
l'hospitalisation de victor son père
appelle régulièrement le service pour
avoir des nouvelles de son fils
voilà donc on vous a dit qu'on est bien
dormir
il a refait une crise convulsive fini
puisque en fait avec 36 kg et ne
semblait pas y avoir en crise mais ouais
il écouterait aliments qu'un nouvel
transfusés on était en train de
commencer la transfusion
et puis oui maintenant on part dans une
rénovation lourde chaque année 150 bébé
comme victor son admission en urgence
tous sont victimes de secousses
violentes occasionnés par des gestes
incontrôlés sans nécessairement
intention de faire mal
on les appelle les bébé secoué
[Applaudissements]
quelques heures plus tard les parents de
victor arrive en réanimation accompagné
du médecin de garde
c'est la machine à fric et le fait
respirer
oui mort une ancienne maintenant il n'a
pas de il n'a pas de commande cérébrales
de ses respirations
donc c'est parce que son cerveau est
complètement au repos
c'est comme une anesthésie quelqu'un qui
est anesthésié n'est pas mort il est son
cerveau ne fonctionne plus de façon
habituelle commandes plus quand on est
obligé de prendre le relais par
l'extérieur mais on va dire qu'il n'ya
plus rien pour l'instant c'est trop tôt
pour vous dire tout va se passer très
très bien on pourra le dire que quand on
constatera
mai
on lui donne là on lui donne toutes ses
chances
ici on ne fait pas que soigner des bébés
victimes de traumatismes inexpliqué on
cherche à comprendre
dominique reynié neurochirurgien dans ce
service il ya cinq ans il a monté avec
son équipe une cellule enfance
maltraitée afin de repérer les familles
à risque et les enfants en danger
leurs expériences montrent que secouer
un enfant provoque des saignements dans
la tête qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences dramatiques sur le cerveau
d'un nourrisson pour faire un hématome
il faut secouer un bébé comme ça très
violemment avec la tête qui ballotte
comme ça très violemment et et peut-être
même les lâchers qui a un impact sur le
lit ou sur le matelas plus dur la
plupart du temps ces missions qui sont
couchés ils pleurent ils vont pas bien
ils ont une otite et on les prend
billard est clos et bondues
contrairement aux idées reçues les 5
années d'expérience de cette équipe
médicale montre qu'en matière de
maltraitance tout le monde est concerné
et personne n'est à l'abri
ça peut arriver à tout le monde dans la
mesure où n'importe qui peut avoir un
moment de fatigue un moment de déprime
un moment de colère et secours et
secouer son enfant et n'importe qui peut
le faire aussi bien la mère le père
l'oncle attente le vent mer la nourrice
n'importe qui
ça peut arriver à n'importe qui mais il
ya des éléments de risque ce sont
justement les éléments qui font que l'on
ne peut craquer à un problème personnel
a eu une histoire un peu un peu lourde
une difficulté dans le travail une
difficultés sentimentales à souci
quelconque un problème médical tout ce
qui fait baisser la garde
psychologiquement est un facteur de
risque
tous les jours l'équipe médicale se
retrouve en réanimation médecins
infirmières et assistantes sociales se
transmettent les informations sur chaque
enfant malade ce matin philippe
anesthésiste réanimateur et carole
assistantes sociales font le point sur
l'état de santé du petit victor arrivé
la veille
il a
toutes les chances d'avoir
largement animé son cerveau et puis
d'avoir un pronostic
de développement extrêmement mauvais
parce que
l'accord système des convulsions
le fait que ça résiste à la
thérapeutique ça c'est extrêmement
sereine
on n'a pas bien parti
et toi t'as pas vu mes parents n'ont
qu'à three
c'est pas très bien ce qui s'est passé
avant qu'ils arrivent ici
c'est un enfant gardé
m
si
[Musique]
un compromis
on a toi
l'électro du laü ce matin au plus tôt
e
dans la majorité des cas on s'est bien
entendu qu'il ya un problème qui est pas
très nettes mais il faut pas non plus
avoir une idée a priori et se dire c'est
effroyable c'est un enfant c'est un
enfant ce coin c'est ça passe ou au
second plan avant la thérapeutique
urgente et puis après bien entendu et il
est nécessaire de voir ce qui ce qui
s'est passé
à chaque traumatisme le scénario est
pratiquement identique
personne ne raconte ce qu'il s'est passé
aucun récit aucune explication et c'est
justement ça qui éveillent l'attention
des médecins quelque chose manque
les assistantes sociales sont là pour
évaluer les situations et démêler les
faits ce matin carole et au téléphone
avec la nourrice d'un autre bébé le
p'tit louis un bébé qui est arrivé en
début de semaine les premières
interrogations commencent
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer
comment s'est passé mais
regardez depuis quand même
vous entretenez de bonnes relations
étaient parents non
y'a
vous êtes à gré
[Musique]
des questions enfin composent que j'ai
par exemple la nourrice mais composent
ont posé même aux parents sur
l'alimentation le sommeil
l'attitude générale de l'enfant sont
importantes parce que effectivement il
ya les soucis qui peuvent être financier
le fatigue etc il ya aussi par exemple
un enfant qui mangent mal
ça au bout d'un moment ça excellent
parce qu'on ait pas de nourrir et en
plus pour une mère c'est c'est difficile
de ne pas arriver à nourrir son enfant
il ya le sommeil un enfant qui dort pas
qui pleure beaucoup qui est énervé vous
donnez moi encore en journée ça va
passer mais encore s'ils nourrissent
elle a plusieurs mais on imagine au bout
d'un moment comment ça peut se passer
mais un enfant qui dort jamais la nuit
qui pleure beaucoup pareil il va pousser
vers une situation
dramatique la culpabilité moi que je vis
dans les entretiens des parents elle se
traduit déjà par une agression envers
nos je pense que quand ils sont
agressifs envers nous c'est un sentiment
culpabilité qui le qu'il témoigne là
parce que souvent je leur dis et je le
pense encore beaucoup ils sont
responsables de leurs enfants mais
responsable ça veut pas dire accusés et
l'histoire de ce bébé en témoigne le
petit louis c'est lui arrivé il ya huit
jours il présentait un tableau clinique
typique d'un enfant secoué aujourd'hui
il se porte bien et il est hors de
danger malgré cela les médecins le
gardent en observation pour surveiller
son état de santé mais aussi pour tenter
de reconstituer son histoire
elle m'a expliqué qu'après le malaise
qu'il a fait ou visiblement il a
convulsé donc ça c'était quatre jours
avant qu'il soit hospitalisé
elle a appelé son médecin qui lui a dit
que le secoue et donc donc il a été
secouée elle dit on pas violemment mais
il a été lente quand même pour le
réanimer
et elle elle dit il s'est passé quelque
chose tu effet les paroles
bon et sûrement grands
depuis l'hospitalisation de son fils le
papa de louis vient le voir tous les
jours à l'heure du déjeuner
avec sa mère on se sent effectivement
parfois dans une position d'accusé dire
que on sent plus une présomption de
culpabilité qu'une présomption
d'innocence
sur le principe je ne je n'ai je n'ai
rien à redire c'est pas marqué sur ma
tête que je suis pas un bourreau
d'enfants et que je joue pas la comédie
et que rentrer à la maison
je le connais aqoci douaniers et c'est
pas je veux dire c'est
normal de de le prendre pour une
hypothèse ça qu'il ya une différence qui
peut être un petit peu subtil on
souhaiterait que notre honnêteté à ne
pas savoir ne se retourne pas contre moi
qu'est ce qui à mon bonhomme
10 min au mont 6 pour savoir si louis a
été secouée volontairement et malgré un
état de santé satisfaisant les médecins
ont décidé de lui faire une radio
complète du squelette il soupçonne une
fracture mais ils n'en sont pas certains
ils ont convoqué les radiologues pour
avoir leur avis à l'excédent contacts
afin qu' on est inquiet en rien du tout
il est gardé par une nourrice qui
apparemment a pris au dessus de tout
soupçon pour de regarder les jours ça
très bien connecté par an mais voilà
t'il pas que nous arrive un compte rendu
du squelette complet systématique avec
fracture de deux os de l'avant bras
gauche et là avait besoin de votre
expertise mesdames et messieurs est ce
que c'est une fracture oubliez tout
oui c'est comme une fracture tasmane je
crois aussi
mon vocation
c'est qu'il ait eu un traumatisme
ces personnes de la raconte alors que
les trois personnes qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui raconte pas être la balle
et sa moto ne s'est pas bleue c'est une
fracture donc et une fracture qui ici
comme toutes les fractures a occasionné
certainement des douleurs pendant
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
donc au pire c'est parce que le
traumatisme n'est pas avoué est à la
limite au bénéfice du doute c'est
qu'est-ce que la surveillance et pat pas
tellement vigilante et que personne ne
s'est rendu compte que cet enfant avait
en fait très très mal au poignet depuis
plusieurs semaines
mais la radio est difficile à
interpréter certains radiologue émettent
un doute sur de si petits membres les
erreurs sont possibles il semble que ce
soit une fracture mais il n'écarte pas
l'hypothèse d'une tumeur bénigne ou d'un
tassement dos dominique reynié attend
leur décision est ce que tu te vois dans
ses parents puisque j'avais un très bon
contact avec eux
il y à une légion sur le poignet de
votre enfant de voile et alors
mais ça leur ait d'autres venus de 17
et félicitations quand on laisse
également judicieux ont dépensé à une
fois cuit rendra également la condition
du patient la décision est importante
car au moindre soupçon de maltraitance
la loi impose de faire un signalement
judiciaire l'hôpital a l'obligation de
rédiger un rapport au procureur de la
république pour que le parquet des
mineurs déclenché une enquête de police
mais ici la situation est parfois plus
complexe selon les cas l'équipe médicale
interprète la loi l'histoire de louis
n'est pas clair le diagnostic des
radiologues n'étant pas formelle les
médecins ont du mal à se faire une
opinion
si on additionne tous hématome sous
dural eu ces mots ratio fonds des
fractures du bras de la voix
[Musique]
normalement ça doit aboutir au
signalement à l'évidence
problème c'est que cette fracture à
l'avant-bras n'est pas sûr et certain on
ne peut pas ne pas le juré c'est là où
on est on est là la frontière de ce qui
est rationnel de ce qui ne l'est pas de
ce qui est objectif de ce qui est
subjectif par rapport à la décision de
toute façon on a toujours et toujours un
risque laisser sortir un enfant peut
jamais être sûr même s'il enquête a dit
on est parent rien fait on a toujours un
risque
c'est pas parce que les parents disent
on n'a rien fait que forcément laissant
rien fait on peut croquer darin et c'est
moi ya une seule situation où je me
souviens mon année c'est sortir l'enfant
et les revenus avec de nouveaux
fracturé m'attribue râle mais sinon si
ce n est jamais arrivée qui selon une
fois quand je dis que il n'ya aucune
classe sociale est à l'abri de secouer
son enfant c'est pas une théorie c'est
une observation pratique on a vu des
avocats des pharmaciens des médecins
des conseillers de ministres
on a vu des gens qui étaient a priori
au dessus de tout soupçon c'est à dire
que l'image qui consiste à penser que ce
sont les chômeurs les alcooliques les
drogués
les défavorisés qui se comptent plus
leurs enfants que les autres est fausse
les médecins ont annoncé à la maman de
louis qu'il pouvait quitter l'hôpital
cet après-midi avant le départ elle doit
passer un dernier entretien le dr hirsch
et carole l'assistante sociale dont un
discours franc et ne lui cache rien
on sait toujours pas pourquoi il a cédé
ma tour n'ont plus de nom mais c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il faut peut-être quand
même discuté un peu de maths de gâter
les enfants
parce que à quoi vous avez un comment
vous avez réfléchi par rapport à sa rage
ne change rien ne change pas de nom de
ta voyez quelque part ça moi ça me
heurte parce que vous pouvez être sûr de
vous même par rapport aux gestes que
vous avez pu faire avec l'enfant
comprend soit vous votre marine qu'un où
les enfants mais vous pouvez pas être
sûr à 100% qu'il soit rien passé avec
elle je peux pas dire si s'est rien
passé six mois je ne sais pas je peux
pas vous le je rêve je suis pas plus
chez moi que chez la nourrice et pas
plus de vous
elle est là un discours qui dit qui est
que si s'est passé quelque chose c'est
pas chez moi c'est fait les parents donc
ce qui est sûr c'est que moi je vais
faire un rapport à la protection
la fatigue ou de votre quartier bon pour
le moment on a décidé de passer la main
dans la mesure où
vous faire confiance que il ya des
choses qui sont pas claires par exemple
l'histoire de cette fracture même au
niveau médical louis privat qui nous
empêche parce que nous sommes pas semble
pourtant persuadé qu'il s'agit d'une
voiture l'autre côté on si c'est pas ça
on sait pas très bien ce que c'est et on
a quand même fait beaucoup d'examens
qui sont pas 100 % claire l'éclairage
mais la natation ça craint
donc c'est pour ça qu'on ne fait pas
mais je vais vous dire qu'on n'a pas été
très loin de le faire
au même moment à les tâches de
réanimation les traits sont tirés les
visages fermés le petit victor le bébé
arrivé la veille aux urgences vient de
mourir il faut aller l'annoncé aux
parents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une évolution
naturelle
contre laquelle ont d'abord on peut pas
aller parce que
on
ça marche pas
et
c'est une évolution et
à la limite mieux pour lui compte tenu
du diagnostic posé l'hématome sous dural
des hémorragies au fond d'oeil tâches
différentes plusieurs épisodes on est
dans l'obligation de remettre ça un
petit peu au niveau dans les mains de la
justice dont je vous ai préparé mais il
ya une tierce personne qui s'est occupée
et c'est nécessaire qu'ils manquaient de
tels obstacles inigo légale qui va
déclencher l autopsie mais qui va aussi
déclenché une enquête de police
le décès de victor va être au centre de
la réunion du mercredi toutes les
semaines l'équipe se réunit pendant
plusieurs heures pour faire face à tous
ces problèmes et évaluer ensemble
situations
neurochirurgien assistante sociale
psychologue mais aussi infirmière chacun
donne ici son avis sur l'enfant et sa
famille le père il était quand même
limite agressif
entretien
avec arrêt mais
comme une chose comme ça pourrait être
une réaction normale les 1500 choque pas
mais c'est vrai qu'il était limite
agressif il n'était pas très content de
tout ce qu'on leur disait
n'est pas que d'en prendre un beau ils
me demandaient ils m'ont demandé si
c'était vraiment indispensable de faire
une autopsie aurait dit que c'était pas
de notre ressort
que c'est pas nous qui décidons que
c'est
la justice suivra son cours et que je l
ai demandé une autopsie comme maîtrisés
par la chose mais dont d'ailleurs la
question il y avait 6 ans gouverne pas
d'affaires on peut dire c'est que
peut-être tout de suite ils ont pas
envie mais que de toute façon
intermittente ont besoin de savoir à
quelle
sauce elles auraient défendu
leurs questions c'est à quoi ça va
servir alors ça peut s'interpréter de
deux façons ou bien ils ont quelque
chose de très très graves a à cacher et
yvon qu'ils essayent de faire des
démarches ils vont continuer pour
empêcher ça on découvre pas la vérité ça
c'est le scénario noir mais il ya aussi
peut-être que simplement se dire qu'ils
ont une certaine culture et il demande
que va apporter une autopsie alors ça
peut s'interpréter de façon anodine ou
de façon grave ici même à aucun moment
est ce qu'ils se disent on dit qu est ce
qui est arrivé
je me demande ce qui est arrivé ils se
sont en même temps office
et donner tout ce qu'on a vu là il
s'agit très probablement d'un enfant
secoué à plusieurs reprises par dessus
le marché c'est pas cette fois je les
chats perdus
malgré leurs convictions il est souvent
difficile pour les médecins d'approcher
la vérité est de savoir ce qu'il s'est
réellement passé le cas de louis est
similaire au cours de la réunion
l'équipe est aussi revenu sur son
histoire et sa fracture n'étant pas
certaine le médecin a décidé de le faire
sortir sans en parler aux groupes et
sans demander l'avis de marie claire la
psychiatre
de laisser sortir cet enfant à la maison
avec un rendez-vous dans quinze jours
avec un scanner et dans un mois avec une
nouvelle radio du poignet et on s'est
dit on va raconter ça mercredi et on va
secondes et
je crois aussi un homme si vous avez
envie de faire ça le lez
les chats sont partis chez corel jeu
vous pensiez
la radio de l'ubs du poignet je vous ai
raconté moi je suis pas convaincu les
traumas je pousse les radios loge dans
leurs retranchements et ils finissent
par avouer sous la menace certes mais à
part avoué qu'ils ne sont pas sûrs
peut-être une fracture et nous
comme ça intuitivement en être
activement cet enfant n'est pas en
danger en rentrant à la maison
c'est vrai qu'on peut se planter qu'on
est prêt
deuxièmement on raconte toujours des
histoires on s'est plantés par défaut
jamais par excès alors faudrait raconter
des deux histoires sauf que les autres
sont beaucoup plus difficile de raconter
des signalements qui ont été défaits à
tort
ça existe aussi donc on peut se planter
dans les deux sens
elle récuse même une idée faire des
signalements tous les coûts
nous comment tu peux faire un top 10 a
tort parce que l'auteur de police n'a
rien à des jeunes non pas du tout je
vois un signalement qui auraient été les
terres ainsi yahoo perd tout faux cul
par terre dans une famille indique que
ces jeunes inventent n'importe quoi vous
me dites qu'on veut non faut pousser
face à manger
pousser le raisonnement jusqu'au bout
facilement tous les coups pour ouvrir
les parapluies et on revient ce que
faisaient les pédiatres avant qu'on
commence à travailler ici c'est
vachement difficiles ont signalé une
famille à la justice pose à chaque fois
un cas de conscience et un problème
légal mais quelles que soient les
décisions prises tous les enfants qui
pastis ils doivent revenir en
consultation pour un suivi médical mais
aussi psychologiques
ngoa 13 mois il en avait 4 lorsqu'il a
été secoué l'enquète n'a pas réussi à
trouver le responsable entre la nourrice
et les parents dans le doute le juge a
décidé de le placer provisoirement dans
un centre spécialisé aujourd'hui il est
accompagné de son père de sa grand mère
et de sa furie culte rice
y roule
roule plutôt
à chaque île étrange et il a eu quelque
chose et donc
on a vibré tout ça et donc après deux
mois la longue ça dure et c'est c'est
moi j'ai eu un malaise je laisse au coin
et le ce1 monte au cerveau
donc c'était la panique tout de suite
dans ce qui fait que c'est un training
catherine et certaines et puis bon
maintenant il est si la pouponnière et
donc jusqu'à maintenant on se pose des
questions quand est ce qu'on va
récupérer que celle enfin besoin de ses
parents quand est ce qu'on va récupérer
l'enfant puisque heures il aidé les
paroles n'ont rien à voir avec ça
il faut il faut pas que j'ai
systématiquement et maurice on essaye de
comprendre qui a fait quelque chose les
parents peuvent n'avoir rien fait du
tout même inconsciemment
en réfléchissant de ne pas se rappeler
avoir fait quoi que ce soit et donc de
dire que c'est la nourrice puisque ça il
faut que ce soit quelqu'un ou bien se
sentir responsable de quelque chose se
le cacher ou se le cacher et accusé de
la nourrice a tort donc on ne peut pas
acheter ce récit
comme ça sans réflexion c'est le juge
qui acquit du mois d'octobre n'a pas
elle a classé aussi elle a dit c'est bon
tout les parents sur le sens et y a rien
comme les parents donc elle l a oublié
de faire son club et a dit que leur ont
donné les enfants c'est tout c'est
simple c'est tout je ne crois pas non je
ne crois pas ce sont ces constats que
nous faisons notre cadre qui nous arrive
c'est comme ça un tout petit peu plus
compliqué avant le sens que nous on n'a
pas ce séjour c'est en effet que vous
puissiez un jour dire un enfant eh bien
nous avons permis que la vérité soit
faite par ce qui vous demandera lui ce
qui nous est assez oui mais nous on
modère ce qui m'a fait mal comme ça à
fait sûr alors là je veux bien qu'il le
dit les autres lui c'est extrêmement
bien sûr de savoir que le nécessaire
mais où il est fait mais bien sûr mais
s'il ya quelqu'un est la version mise en
espace à 10 cm et je vois pas pourquoi
qu' on ne s'arrête pas on va chercher
quoi on veut séparer de ses parents non
le fait un petit malheureux ben si
justement ceux qui cherchent à faire non
et j'avais dû casser les parents gardent
leur place auprès de 7 oui oui je vous
écoute à vous m'aimez ce qui est
derrière je sais pas moi la justice que
la justice fasse attention un enfant
innocent qui a un havre de dents et que
ses parents non plus et que il fasse
quand même ce qui tuerait faire c'est
vrai je pense que l'eau n'est pas
c'était tout à fait justifiée de placer
ses enfants parce que on ne savait pas
du tout ce qui s'était passé et en fait
on essaie toujours pas on sait qu'il ya
eu un traumatisme assez sévères c'est
quand même très très grave
donc il me semble effectivement très
difficile de rendre cet enfant
directement à ses parents vous avez
détesté s'est replié
un tampon là
rien ne s'est passé mais c'est normal
petit peu hélas
un peu mieux
l
île et j'ai absolument pas
à quelques kilomètres de necker
l'hôpital saint maurice en région
parisienne après leur hospitalisation
tous ces bébés ce qu ils viennent ici en
rééducation beaucoup d'entre eux ont des
pronostics d'évolution à certains un
enfant sur deux aura des séquelles un
sur cinq aura un retard mental important
et un profond handicap dans ce centre
spécialisé on réapprend les premiers
gestes pendant de longs mois une
passerelle nécessaire entre l'hôpital et
la maison on travaille beaucoup avec les
parents les parents sont souvent
longtemps séparé leurs enfants ont pas
de temps privilégié avec leurs enfants
dans les services hospitaliers
donc on essaie ici d'offrir un lieu
on peut se retrouver avec leurs enfants
cet enfant qui parfois les différentes
l'enfant qu'ils ont connue avant parce
que parfois des handicaps qui est un
développement psychomoteur qui retardé
donc on essaye avec les parents de leur
montrer ce que l'enfant fait quelles
sont ses compétences et comment il parle
interagir ensemble donc ce qu'on utilise
beaucoup c'est le
toucher sensorielle c'est à dire qu'on a
comparé ans à reprendre contact avec
notre bébé par un touché wheeler touche
les gens en coucou ou
entre autres quand l'enfant à une
d'hémiplégie et c'est important de
toucher le côté qui est unique léger
pour que faire comprendre ça fait partie
de son corps ça fait
m même s'il couche
mais pour tous ces bébés la rééducation
ne s'arrête pas là au jardin d'enfants
les éducatrices l'airé apprivoise jour
après jour un autre site
certains enfants on sent une méfiance et
l'adulte doit s'approcher d'eux vraiment
avec beaucoup de jeux d'hier est
délicate et c'est vraiment prendre en
compte lors et en l'état
dans lequel arrivent quand on sait
exactement qu'un parent un moment donné
a eu ce genre de comportement c'est
peut-être plus facile à prendre en
charge parce qu'on sait exactement à
quel moment il ya un risque et les
parents qui ont pris conscience avoir un
moment puis à de violents avec leurs
enfants on peut faire tout un travail de
prise de conscience du besoin de
l'enfant qu'est ce qui est dangereux
pour l'enfant de quoi il a besoin qu'un
moment ça peut déraper et langue peut
repartir sur de nouvelles bases
[Musique]
adrien lui aussi est passé par de longs
mois de rééducation avant de retrouver
sa maison et sa famille à l'époque du
drame il avait seulement deux mois et
demi ces parts ont été appelés d'urgence
parce qu'il avait fait un malaise chez
sa nourrice à l'hôpital on leur a dit
qu'ils avaient été secoué très
violemment trois ans après adrien
gardent d'importantes séquelles
il a massacré il venait à peine de
naître et il a vécu deux mois et demi et
qui même après ces maudits pour lucas
quand c'est quoi c'est une deuxième
naissance folle ce compte il est sorti
du coma
c'est vraiment une deuxième naissance à
dire qu'il souriait plus il tenait plus
à tête gazouiller plus au début savait
même plus tu étais ils étaient tous nous
ils avaient plus de regards parce
qu'avec le sang versé il voyait plus
rien puis ses yeux partait dans tous les
sens donc c'est vraiment un autre bébé
qu'il a fait redécouvrir
qui a fallu aussi passé des tas de radio
mais surtout tout ton corps pour savoir
s'il n'est pas d'autres séquelles
ailleurs et puis c'est là qu'on s'est
aperçu que
bah ils ont vu qu'il y avait une
clavicule qui avait été cassée d
arrachement osseux
donc quand on vous a rajouté tout ça j
c'est vrai qu'on a c'est clairement un
massacre un enfant cotonou ctc sa course
et ça s'est passé pas seulement le truc
anodin c'est le syndrome du bébé secoué
quoi et puis qu'est vraiment pour
attraper un gamin qui devait secouer ses
yeux la manche alors qu'il sait pas
secouer comme ça c'est souhaiterait
violemment secoué comme un prunier quoi
c'est vraiment c'est pas la petite
secousse anodine c'est il a été secouée
violemment qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ben
ali a gardé les graphes malvoyance
puisqu'il a en fait qu'un dixième à
l'oeil droit et l'oeil gauche ne voit
que le jour et la lumière se porte comme
ça c'est là une des plus graves
séquelles qu'il a gardé de ce centre qui
s'est répandu dans sa tête
et son petit hémiplégie à droite mais ô
vous a dit qu'il perdrait au niveau des
jambes et au niveau de la main qui
pourrait peut-être se servir de sa main
sans avoir une motricité très fine il
faudrait quand même se servait la
nourrice a été mis en examen
[Musique]
ça empêche paraître effectivement ça
arrive sur un sur hanoi au clan et donc
on fait appel parce que bien sûr on
n'est pas content on n'est pas du tout
satisfait du non-lieu et puis
on voudrait en plus il ya des éléments
dans les dents dans le dossier qui non
pas qu'ils n'ont pas été traités comme
pas traitée suffisamment bien
dans ce genre d'affaires il existe
rarement de preuves matérielles si
personne n'avoue l'enquète abouti la
plupart du temps un non lieu les deux se
finisse par être classés et personne ne
sera jamais ce qu'il s'est réellement
passé l'année dernière sur quarante
quatre signalements effectués par
l'équipe de necker 13 ont fait l'objet
de classements sans suite
[Musique]